[Music]
this is star talk sports edition i'm
neil degrass tyson your personal
astrophysicist bringing to you this
episode which we've titled nature versus
nurture and by the way i hate that
debate nature versus nurture but
sometimes you have to resurrect it
because you're confronted with something
you cannot otherwise explain
without duking it out over whether
nature or nurture matters because in
this episode we are featuring my
exclusive sit-down interview with eli
manning
eli manning super bowl winning
quarterback for the new york giants
brother of another super bowl winning
quarterback both of whom were sons of an
nfl quarterback so there's a lot going
on in that family and there's a lot to
talk about in this show i've got my
co-host chuck nice to meet you neil i
hate this show too
just hate it so much
so yeah so so chuck with no actual
athletic experience he's here to bring a
touch of levity if you don't otherwise
know that but i do have gary o'reilly
gary hey neil
all right good i do love this show just
as uh
just so is the illegitimate stepchild of
podcast get some love somewhere along
the line there you go yeah yeah former
uh football uh pro baller over in the uk
and it's always great to have you you
also serve time as an announcer there
yeah so we didn't just pluck you off the
field you you were you were honed in all
the ways necessary to do what we need
you to do for this show
so it's like we have to ask
did were were the manning brothers
manufactured
because of the environment in which they
were raised by their father or is there
some genetic component that we need to
pay attention to
and to do this i think we need some
academic expertise
and who do we call
we're gonna call there's only one person
in the universe who can comment on this
with depth uh and intensity and
expertise and that's angela duckworth
angela welcome back to star talk hey
guys it's great to be with you again i
love this show already by the way even
though excellent even though i'm with
you the the nature versus nurture the
only problem is the verses part but yeah
that's it that's the verses that's maybe
that's why i should have localized it
yeah to to the verses part and i just
want you to know chuck that angela
wrote the book on grit she actually did
lit yes wait a minute literally
literally literally what happened there
what oh my god
you see what i did
all over the place
so she's a professor of psychology at
psychology university of pennsylvania
she studies like grit in fact she's
largely responsible for that word being
in our vocabulary in the way we use it
grit and self-control
and uh she's also um founded the
character lab this is audacious a
founder and ceo of this the character
lab um it's a not-for-profit
organization to advance the science and
practice of character development
something we haven't heard much of
lately
and and there it is author of grit
the power of passion and perseverance
and that was released five years ago
back in 2016 and it was on the new york
times bestsellers for 21 weeks so it hit
it in accord with many many people and
so
so so angela we have you here to reflect
on these clips of mine when i sat down
caught up with eli manning up in uh
where was he was in connecticut if you
come came from a house where everybody's
got to win
like what does that mean in his
early years is this good force is it a
bad force and i want to get angela's
reaction angela when we after you take a
listen to this clip so here we are my
first clip of several uh in conversation
with eli manning the way you describe
this tells me that at no time did you
feel pressure
you know that parental pressure that's
my boy out there he's gonna check him
out and then now you gotta perform
because otherwise you'll disappoint
right your parents so what what was that
relationship you know my dad uh my dad
loved
for us to play sports he played sports
and you know growing up there was an
important part of his life he but more
on that he was pro he was a professor he
played 14 years in nfl he played
baseball in college he was as well and
so he he just you know grew up playing
sports as a young boy and so he just
thought it built great character it
built you know just uh a good work ethic
it helped with you know teamwork and and
dealing with the good and the bad that
happened to you in life and so um he
wanted us to play sports but his rule
was he says um you know you have to ask
me
you know so we had to ask him
to go you know throw the football with
us or go shoot hoops with us or go you
know make catch it was not the other way
around we had to be in charge of our own
athletics and your own initiative in our
own initiative it had to it had to start
from us and if we asked him you know he
would drop and and go out there that is
the complete opposite
of the way most parents run that play
it's okay
i know it's like you're playing we're
gonna catch today
whether you like it or not get out here
right now we gotta catch a hundred balls
you can make 100 free throws i think the
fact that he i mean he he lived his
athletic career like he wasn't trying to
live his sports life through us he did
his own he had 14 years in the nfl he
was just trying to raise three boys to
be good kids do well in school and you
know and create a a you know make sports
being positive and fun and that's how i
think he was raised and so he tried to
do the same with us so angela
this sounds like the ideal environment
to not have the pressure but still have
the
the tap roots to grow
so is this the kind of family that that
works for you i think this is not only
the kind of family that raises you know
two quarterbacks um who have you know
storied careers but it's just the kind
of family that raises great kids you
know um this um
clip reminds me of uh you know one of
the core tenets of motivational
psychology and also what we know about
the science of parenting which is that
human beings of all ages but especially
kids have a huge um
need for autonomy um the ability to make
the choice the ability to say you know i
want to do this not that and um this
need for autonomy is in a way it's like
you think what's the well that's kind of
obvious like you know everyone's it's
like the opposite of tiger parenting
which is actually what a lot of people
um mistakenly think
is that you know the the roots of
greatness is that you have some parent
who's like making you do all these hard
things that you know 15 years later
you're glad that they forced you to do
that and in fact the research is
unequivocal that um when you
take away choices from your kids
they they lose intrinsic motivation and
you know you can keep them going for a
while just by like browbeating them into
practicing their piano or whatever but
they'll never be great i think that's
you know one of the things that i would
would say also of my research that when
you look into the childhoods of people
who eventually become great um it's hard
to find evidence of this kind of
coercive parenting that you know some
people call tiger parenting what what if
you what did you actually recognize in
your child um a gift if you want to call
it that a certain proclivity towards uh
greatness in an area and you don't want
them to squander
and so you're just like hey man no you
got to do this but then they catch on to
the fact that they are great and then
that kind of gets the ball rolling and
they take over
yes how often does that happen okay so
chuck's bringing up a really good point
i want to actually say there's two
things i mean so rule number one for
parenting is respect for autonomy right
respect for the autonomy of your kid um
but there's two um i don't know
corollaries or like footnotes asterisks
because it's not that easy right anybody
who's been a parent knows that you have
to
occasionally uh like tell your kids to
do things that they don't want to do so
that's you know in a way not respecting
their autonomy right like no you can't
cross the street right now like no you
can't take that but here here are the
two asterisks i want to put on the like
need for autonomy parenting advice
one is that once your kid is committed
you know to football or whatever you
know like i'm going to be on the school
newspaper this year etc i do think and
this is also from my own parenting
experience um because i've got an 18 and
19 year old two girls right like yeah
you as a parent do have to enforce their
decision right once they have said
autonomously
yeah i'm gonna do track right but then
after the first track meet this is what
happened to my younger daughter lucy she
was like oh
changed my mind i didn't like it after
all right and i was like no problem
there's only seven more weeks of track
season and then you can make another
choice so i do think you have to enforce
the commitments i mean you know what kid
really is going to say like hey it's a
really sunny day outside like i really
want to like practice this instrument
you know violin that i that i said that
i wanted to practice so i think the
first asterisk is like yeah parents have
to
help their kids like meet their
commitments but the commitment comes
from the kid
um and the second one is like what you
just said chuck right like there are
times where um and i think uh you know i
have a research project on this right
now but there are times where our
confidence falters right it's not like
there's no variation in your confidence
that like every day you wake up and
you're like i can do this and i
absolutely think that it is an
enormously important thing for a parent
or anybody else like a coach right to
say like i know you don't believe in
yourself today right and i know you want
to quit because you don't think you can
do this but i'm not letting you quit on
a bad day and so they're a buoyant force
in what's going on they're a buoyant
force especially when it comes to
confidence and i think um very often the
the kid is myopic the parent can see far
yeah well let's find out what what makes
eli manning tick let's go to my second
clip
in my exclusive conversation with this
new york giants football great eli
manning check it out
people can't stop wondering
was it in the water supply or in the
food in the biscuits your parents bake
for your family you you and your brother
and your father and you have there's
another sibling right another our oldest
brother cooper played football he was a
receiver and then had a neck injury had
to stop oh that's too bad but but
nonetheless all of three of you were
engaged yes in this way yes is it the
food
is it the air you breathe is it
what is your
analysis
you know what uh i think it's just a
sense of
some people you know like i talked about
earlier some people can just they can
get a ball and they could say i'm going
to throw it and hit that tree and for
whatever reason without thinking about
it your body just you know moves and you
create torque and you get arm angle and
it all just flows and if you had if i
had to think about how to throw a
football like what are your hips do and
what does your shoulder do i would have
no idea it's like if i had to think
about it i might not be able to throw it
so i just you know you just you can just
it's just a natural
motion that we could we could do and it
just made sense to us and then we also
enjoyed
you know kind of uh
learning about the game of football and
learning hey why our defense is playing
this you know this this style of defense
why what's this coverage what are good
plays to go against this coverage it's
kind of you're figuring out the
equations like a math equation you're
figuring out the answer hey they play
this defense we run this play we'll have
success we'll create that touchdown
which is kind of the final answer he
came at this by saying oh i did this and
it felt natural
and then he pursued what he would then
call his natural proclivity his natural
ability so angela
is there is it fair to say that some
people have a natural ability because
because i can practice at something and
get better at it and nobody's going to
call it natural if i practice that but
if the end result is the same why are we
even distinguishing between the two i
think there's such a um you know
reflexive you know is it innate talent
or is it something that you can practice
i mean you know very similar to the is
it nature or is it nurture dichotomy um
when the the messy truth is that it's
almost got to be both right so what we
know from behavioral genetics is there's
nothing about us you know our ability to
throw a football the first time that we
get one in our hands or you know a math
equation or you know to like sing a song
or to be extroverted like literally
everything about us has some genetic
influence the dna that cuts shuffled and
that we inherited from our mom
biological mom and our biological dad
like it influences everything about us
so there's got to be an extent to which
you can say that the mannings have
a gene pool
that inclines them toward that you know
multifaceted ability that adds up to
being a great quarterback or a great
athlete
at the same time every single one of
those things that i mentioned being
extroverted being able to throw football
you know the first time you get um a
chance to sing like what happens those
things are all malleable and they are
practicable and so if we could get
people to out of this conversation neil
get out of the kind of either or
thinking when it comes to their own kids
or or themselves into both and thinking
yeah there's both some genetic influence
and there's a hell of a lot i can do to
actually change things when he talks
about his young days and obviously the
physical aspect of him being able to
throw intuitively is is there but he
talks about his enjoyment
of problem solving as a quarterback is
this him really beginning to unlock his
true potential
gary i'm so glad you brought that up i
noted that as well and by the way
enjoying running around you know
enjoying athletic activity and joining
you know what some um uh psychologists
just like kinesthetic intelligence right
you know the the where my body is in
space like where everybody else's body
is in space that kind of thing
that is also both nature and nurture
right so absolutely some kids are born
enjoying that more or enjoying music
more or whatever at the same time
experience matters um you know one of
the things that the manning story uh
brings to mind is a study done at
university of chicago um now several
decades ago by a great psychologist
named benjamin bloom but angela we don't
have time to hear that study in this
segment but if our audience can hang on
and so can you when we come back we'll
pick up that story on what research has
to say about what's going on in the
manny family on star talk
we're back star talk sports edition i
got chuck and gary with me of course
and we've got angela duckworth to help
us understand and interpret and analyze
my exclusive interview with nfl football
great eli manning and angela you were
saying after we heard those first two
clips that it reminded you of some
research that you're about to quote tell
us what's going on there when you ask a
great performer you know why it is that
they're great they usually say something
about enjoying learning about what
they're doing i mean they just really
enjoy
music or football whatever it is now
this research that i was um
getting into was done by benjamin bloom
at university of chicago he looked at
120 world class performers
swimming um neuroscience sculpture uh
piano tennis and people top of their
game at the very top of their game and
he actually interviewed people yeah like
typically like for example like when
they were so far into their careers that
they everybody knew they were great but
that their parents and their
coaches were still alive to also be
interviewed and one of the things that
came out is that when you talk about
like cultivating um an enjoyment of a
craft
which like everything else we're talking
about today is not only nature but also
nurture like what is that nurture part i
think there's two things one is that
somebody in that young kid's life is
actually modeling enjoying that craft
and very often it was their parents so
in the way that perhaps you know archie
manning was just demonstrating just it
was a personal example like how
wonderful sports was like how terrific
archie manny the father the father
exactly of the two of the two boys right
who would grow up so so that happened
over and over again in these stories of
120 world-class performers doesn't mean
that if your your mom or dad isn't
already like the thing that you're gonna
grow up to be that you'll you'll never
love it but it does actually make it
more likely and i happen to think that
um you know a parent who models passion
for something is also you know a
powerful role model just that you're
that you're really into something and
your kids should watch that and
appreciate that um and then the you know
the second thing i'll just say about
this benjamin bloom study is at the same
time they always do respect that kid's
autonomy right so so it's not forcing
your kids to go into the thing that you
love but modeling that you do love it
and encouraging them and you know just
like eli manning said you have to ask me
but if you do ask me yeah i'm gonna go
throw the ball around with you
well i in my interview i did ask him
directly what he thought about the
nature versus nurture question in his
own life let's check it out can anybody
become
you what and what what
what does that mean are we talking like
clones here
where are we going with this uh
you know if i
if i want to be a football star and
let's say i'm in middle school or high
school
um if i just worked hard at it
can i become you or do you think there
might have been some genetic profile
that that you came out of your mother
with
where you just you were just ready and
born for it no i definitely think there
is some sort of like you're born with a
certain skill set and and and some
people
you know whether it's throwing throwing
a ball throwing a football shooting a
basket it just makes sense to them and
and i i relate it to golf you know i
think there's some people that can just
hit a golf ball they get up there and
this the the hips and the arms and
everything is in sync and for me
i've played so much golf and it's i mean
i'm okay but i'll never be able to get
to that professional level i mean i
could i could get a coach and i could
practice every single day and i've kind
of i'm just limited in certain things
and i think that's just the way it is in
certain sports you can improve and you
can get better but there's going to be
some limitations that if if you don't
have
these certain skill sets or don't skill
sets or have this certain mobility that
you can't create that to get to the top
of the top level so angela would you say
that
maybe what people should do is explore
everything they could be good at
and and then make a list of that and
then find out of what you could be good
at what you enjoy doing most
and then this filters down to just what
we need how
this filters down to how we should
perhaps be investing our time and energy
there have got to be some
genetic limits for example height right
i mean you know
you look at the olympics and it's like
wow none of these gymnasts are six foot
six right like and you know it turns out
none of the basketball players are five
foot one right but but you know that's
just one example right there have to be
some uh genetic limits but also just
some genetic weightings right some
things where it's like well yeah you can
climb that slope but it's going to be
really steep for you but for this other
person it's going to be easy downhill
walking so there's got to be um you know
where so is chuck genetically funny
well i have thought about humor actually
which is really you know the same thing
to me as like you know sports or chess
or astrophysics right okay all right
like it's a it's a skill it's a craft
it's a love it's a passion you know you
get better at it i think chuck right
like you could argue the only difference
is you um you you certainly don't
want to model passion for it in front of
your children because you don't want
them to become comedians
whatever you do don't do
well uh that that may be the only
exception right because everything else
i think um applies and you know when um
when eli talks about being born with a
certain skill set i mean it's an
interesting choice of words because i i
don't know that you know the human brain
is not born actually like pre-wired with
like you know how to throw a long pass
right like that's angela let me ask you
this question yeah right uh there are
those athletes that don't match the
physical perfection of their event but
they still make it
they're still successful
so what's their pathway
in looking at what they don't have and
making up in other ways to achieve the
goal they're set out for some of the
greatest basketball players alive today
right aren't the tallest ones on the
team i mean that just wouldn't be you
know something that you would expect i
mean some of them are like real so that
would be an example right gary i think
i'm just saying that there are
obviously some things which do make it
harder or even in some sports you could
argue like just impossible right like
you know there are certain like very
extreme things where you're like that's
i i will say that um but just to be
clear michael jordan was 6'6 i think
that's right yeah
like amazing
okay right and given the choice of you
know given a magic wand you know these
players may be like yeah give me the
other inch like give me the five inches
right so so i do think there are
advantages and disadvantages like again
i wouldn't call them skill sets because
i it's you know the human brain is
actually plastic and so it is um what um
some scientists would call experience
dependent and experience expectant so
there might be like proclivities right
like you know like it's prepared
interesting phrasing i like that yeah
you know but it's not like you're born
with a kid who actually knows how to do
anything right like think of babies like
they know how to talk but they are born
like prepared to learn how to talk um so
there's angela i thought our brains were
made of organic matter and not plastic
yes so this is a i learned something
every day
metaphorically i don't know why we say
that because i don't even know if
plastic is that plastic
it's not even stretchable right right
it's not plastic doesn't stretch okay
big airplanes out of plastic
there you go so we got to get to my our
next clip the next clip uh eli manning
comments on the value of being at the
right place even at the right time check
it out when you realize you could throw
a ball and hit the tree
that's good
but
clearly you would have to further refine
that sure to be to win championships
either in high school or in college
or in the nfl right so wherever you
began
how far did you
train yourself relative to where you
sort of walked in the door right about
that that's the question yeah no i mean
it took a lot of a lot of training and a
lot of work and i mean
and it's i think it does go back to
you know those times when you're in
you're in grade school and you're out
for recess with the kids and you're
playing pickup games and you know i
played quarterback and you know our team
whatever team i was on we would usually
win because i was a better quarterback
than the other team so then they made me
permanent quarterback i was on both
sides to kind of create an equal game
for everybody else but i think those
added
it was so uneven when you're on one side
right they have to share you share me
but but i think all those throws like
add up that i wasn't practicing right
there i wasn't practicing to become an
nfl player but those added up but so but
so by the time i got to high school when
i remember high school
um i would go uh i i remember i used to
work out with a guy named tom shaw he
was a speed specialist and he worked
with a lot of college guys and nfl
players i lived in new orleans with the
new oregon saints and so he was training
a lot of nfl players
and they wanted to throw routes
afterwards and then he didn't have a
quarterback to train with them so in
high school he asked if i would go and
he would train me on running but if i
would throw to his receivers so in high
school in the summer i'm throwing the
college and nfl receivers all summer and
so like all those things that also that
point now you're now you're training now
you're practicing this isn't recess this
is like hey i've got and and i'm
learning from these receivers how to
throw these routes and how to throw
20-yard comebacks and go routes and i'm
like i don't want to throw an
incompletion because i don't want this
you know 10-year nfl vet yelling at me
for throwing a bad route and so you know
it's just it you know the training
started there
and all that all those throws add up so
angela is this a is this just another
way to say he spent ten thousand hours
honing his craft
the the research on deliberate practice
the kind of practice that experts like
the mannings um
exemplify um which by the way as you
know um all of you know it's not exactly
ten thousand hours but it is true that
across every domain that's been studied
you know
everyone uh it's always thousands of
hours i mean it just gives you a sense
of the magnitude of like how long it
takes to become
really world class at whatever you do
yes what he's talking about when he said
oh this wasn't just playing this was now
trying to become better
at this thing that i'm doing
that is where you cross the line and
going back to benjamin bloom the
university of chicago scientist who
studied the world class performers there
was what he called the early years the
middle years and then the later years
and the early years are a play it's like
oh it's just fun and you know it was
like recess and then like turns out and
then you cross this line and you enter
the middle years and that's when you
start doing deliberate practice and the
motivation i think then becomes like to
get better and i think the the thing
that i note about the world-class
achievers that i've studied is that they
love to one-up well other people
especially if they're athletes but they
love to one-up themselves so that
motivation to get better at what you're
doing just turns on in the middle years
yeah okay so what happens then angela
when you put someone like eli manning
and you hot house him as a high school
student with nfl players
and then what's the burn rate for these
young athletes or even younger than high
school burn out burnout rate yeah so
what is what is that and the
psychological damage that you can put
into a young person's mind i think the
the chief error that benjamin bloom also
studied um was when you skip the early
years right the kind of intrinsic
motivation like i choose to do this this
is so fun of all the things i could do i
really want to do this mom and dad then
when you pass into the middle years you
have a foundation of love for the sport
and you don't really necessarily lose
that it's just that you're now adding on
this need for challenge this need for
improvement i think where you get
burnout is when you skip the early years
and you forget how important it is that
the kid actually chose this to begin
with um not to say that it's the only
problem obviously you can train to
exhaustion you can over train etc
and i think it's always helpful to
remember that in this research
where you have different motivations at
different stages and by the way
different coaches at different stages
who really understand that aspect of the
game the the ideal performer never loses
the motivation of the earlier stages so
the first stage is like this is fun the
second stage is i can get better and by
the way the third stage is to have a
sense of purpose i have a sense that
what you're doing is beyond the self and
so ideally when you get to that that
third stage you still have that kind of
you know this is fun and you still have
the like wow i can get back the great
thing is you see that when you look at
elite players and by that i mean anybody
on a professional level uh they are
deadly serious during the execution of
whatever the sport might be
but
their deadly seriousness always erupts
into childlike joy when they have an
achievement and so it's like here are
these guys battling it out manu amano
all the way down
and then they make a touchdown and it's
like
right and they're shaking their name
oh they're dancing in their favorite
in baseball if someone hits a walk-off
gets a walk-off hit or a home run uh
then they come around the base repeat
they're jumping up and down and dumping
the gatorade on each other that that'll
be the win bonus neil
well that'll be the touchdown bonus that
every athlete gets we're gonna take
another break when we come back angela
if you can stay with us for that one
last segment we got more for you and
plus we're going to find out forget
angela we're going to find out what eli
thinks can make you successful good
start talk sports edition
continues
we're back star talk sports edition
featuring my interview sit down
exclusive interview with
super bowl great new york giant great
eli manning
and for this next
[Music]
chuck is from philadelphia okay it took
this slow green
so let's go straight to this next clip
where eli manning has a checklist
of what it takes to be success because
forget anything that angela just told
you we're going to get it from eli
manning himself here it is there's some
families that have a really great
athlete in among the siblings and the
rest are not
so
it's not a given
that some genetic profile
out of a
you know a family
it doesn't guarantee that everybody
becomes
successful sure
so do you have any
bits of wisdom you can just put out
there that
other people can absorb
in their ambitions yeah i mean i think i
think a a strong work ethic i think a
strong
mental
you know mindset and just being driven
uh the kind of the power of the will uh
is much more important
than the natural talents and so you see
people who are just determined are the
ones that go out there and are
successful and and those are the guys
you can count on they're the best
teammates because you know they're doing
everything possible uh for the
betterment of the team and so there's
you know i would challenge people what
and not just sports but in science and
in school work it's the people that uh
that are driven that work harder
and that
you know or in a lot of cases kind of
maybe doing it not only for themselves
but doing it for someone else uh that
they get the most out of it and and
become successful okay so eli had his
own ideas i think i actually i i i
prefer what the answer is you still
forget what angela said i'm just like
that guy doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about
so let's get let's go
let's get back to angela quick on that
one look you can get back to both of us
because i think we're like violently
agreeing right i mean
yeah that's the way i felt right i mean
he talked about like this um you know
mental mindset like the you know the
people who are really determined like
you know you can count on them like you
know you don't even have to be watching
what they're doing all the time because
when nobody's watching they're
practicing right and and i think um when
he says like that might in his own rank
ordering right this is eli's not mine
like that that um that he would put that
above
natural talent well i would choose the
same rank ordering um but here's the
thing i also want to underline you know
he said like you know when you really
look into what these people are doing
it's like they're doing it for not just
for themselves right like they have a
sense of purpose which is greater than
themselves and i've been um
shocked actually to find that it's not
only athletes in team sports like
football where that might be
understandable or basketball right
baseball but also individual sports like
downhill skiing or like where there is a
sense of beyond the self motivation and
i just don't think people get up out of
the morning you know in the morning out
of bed at like five in the morning
whatever it is um when it's only for
themselves i think there's something
deeply
human about the need to serve other
people
well and team sports can can inculcate
that very very easily i want to make
sure we have time for this final clip so
i'm going to go to it right now and it's
eli brings up the topic
which has been in all the news as the
mental health and well-being of
professional athletes especially those
that are performing in very very public
settings
and he decided to take
control of his own mental health let's
check it out so at what point did you
realize
if ever
that
your mind had to be a part of that
effort
because we are sensitized in recent
months and years to
high performance high profile athletes
who stepped out of the of the big game
or the big contest
because they needed some
mental time
yeah and i think uh in in 2007 so my
fourth year in the nfl
uh is when i i uh reached out and got a
a a sports psychiatrist to start working
with
and that's when it you know just kind of
realized hey you lift weights
you you study film you practice
and yet you know there was this one
thing out you kind of left out the
middle approach to it in your mind if
your mind's not in the right spot if
you're not thinking positively if you're
not prepared to go out there and be your
best then it's not going to happen
whatever the mind thinks it's usually
what the body is what's
and so
uh and then you know that year went on
to win a super bowl and had success and
so i just
um you know i think it is so important
and like you said you see it now with
some athletes in the olympics and uh and
tennis and other sports you know this
you know kind of not be able to handle
uh some of those circumstances and so
you you you know understand that the
mind is so important and um and you can
do it you know you kind of learn that i
remember 2007 just doing a lot of visual
visualizations and also and you're like
sitting there in a chair like this
thinking about a two-minute drive in the
game and you're having this you're
smelling the smell of the stadium you're
hearing the crowds you're running the
plays and you're sweating i mean it's
65 degrees in the room and you're in a
full sweat and so you realize the power
of the mind what it can create
so maybe it's been long overdue where we
would fully accept if you had an elbow
injury or knee injury of course you're
gonna miss a few games so maybe the time
has come where someone needs some mental
recovery
time that that's no different
in a in in the total
package that an athlete represents yeah
i think it's just it is harder to accept
i think as as you can see you can you
know you can feel
your knees pain a doctor says boom your
knee is hurt here's the mri hey your
your bone is broken here's an x-ray
you know it's hard to look into the mind
into just the mental state of someone
you think that well that's easy to fix
and it's not i mean you can you can
definitely get in that bad you know in a
be in a bad place and a bad position to
be thinking negative thoughts and i
think you know people would say well you
just got to find a way to to to work
through that and grind through it and
and go out there for your teammates and
so it is it is a tough battle but having
been in those kind of in that position
uh i just understand that the mind is
powerful and if it's not in the right
place you're not gonna be able to go out
there and perform very well so angela i
and again i've been hogging all these
questions i want to make sure chuck and
gary have have their their their say
in this but i i want to sort of
take what eli just shared with us and
ask you
isn't there a day when we would have
just said just suck it up and get on
with it that was today and you'd have to
it was early this morning
that's where that was that that was
early this morning
hours ago
so let's assume that that might even be
possible but it's not always in the best
long-term interest of the person's
mental health but it is true that people
have been injured physically and the
coach or they themselves says i'm just
going to suck it up okay we had lindsey
vaughn on this podcast
talk to us about getting injured on some
downhill slope get airlifted out and
then she's back competing the next day
because she didn't want to lose a beat
and meanwhile she's like bandaged and
and
by chewing gum and then bailing wire to
just to continue so here she is sucking
it up and getting on with it so so where
do you what do you advise in terms of
people's mental health
with regard to taking the time off or
not or just sucking it up lindsay's my
girl so now we're now we're talking i
love lindsay we're um uh we're pretty
good friends and i have thought a lot
about like her mental toughness and then
you know the mental toughness of you
know people like eli manning i think
we're in the middle of a revolution
honestly i mean it's not the case that
today people would say like you
literally just have to suck it up or
there's nothing that like for example a
performance psychologist um or even i
think manning said like a performance
psychiatrist i'm not sure you know
whether like he meant exactly that but
that yeah you can get somebody to help
you with your mind just the way you
would get somebody to help you with your
knee or your hip and that revolution so
the stigma has changed you're saying
because yeah we're talking about the
macho sport of american football you
can't go on the sidelines and start
crying because you don't feel good that
day that that's that doesn't play
and but you're saying we're going we're
undergoing a
i [ __ ] i think the fact that you're
seeing it in a you know macho sport like
football is just an indicator that the
whole world must be changing you know
the the um memoir that lindsay just
wrote she talks very um honestly right
also about depression and and about you
know how having to um you know manage
that deal that learn from that and i
think what we're seeing now is that
these high performers are human beings
and as human beings they sometimes need
help from other people they can you know
work on things like their emotions and
they have emotions and so but angela
you're wrong they're not human beings
they're super superheroes
they're super human beings i don't want
to walk down the street and find
superman crying in a phone booth because
he can't see the singing man's having a
bad day
by the way that's
that's batman's job crying yeah right so
here's the here's the deal you walk into
the stadium right from the parking lot
and as the coach and i'm looking at you
can i tell whether or not you're game
ready or you're half baked
and you're not going to be performing
now
you can there's certain tells in the
body language but if you're one of those
people that covers that up i i can't
tell what's going off in here so we need
to have this in here in your mind in my
mind yes so it's one of those things
that now i see it because the way it
used to be is blindfold that guy push
him into a dark room and let's see if he
gets out the other side and you would
fumble your way through this now we have
so much more understanding of you know
what this is a package it's holistic
it's body and mind don't just expect one
thing and one thing alone to carry this
athlete so gary would you just ask now
like whereas before you would just like
you know shove them into and see what
happens i mean i feel like there would
be a conversation you know
whereas you know 20 years ago there
wouldn't be yeah that's because 20 years
20 years ago
we had a lot more anger to feed our
performance
all of these sports were driven by anger
all of the time that you spent becoming
what you were becoming the fact that
this other guy was on the other side of
you it was like i'm going to kill you
that was the game
it wasn't about what is it now wait what
is it now no no no wait wait angela
as you can see chuck still needs though
no now it's about now it's about
performance it's about competitiveness
it's about achievement
you're fueled by something different
from the inside when you look at guys
like jack lambert and ronnie lott these
guys wanted to just
kill them they wanted to kill you
they would do things like you bear the
bottom of a pile and they would bite you
that's not that's not
progress that doesn't have
[Laughter]
so you know
all right guys we gotta try to land this
plane here um angela do you have any
sort of final reflections on
where nothing is final do you have any
any
timely reflections on where society is
now and also
um informed by what we've learned from
eli today you know a lot of people
like me don't know a lot about football
but we nevertheless admire
the mannings all of them right and i
think it's because um they are uh
people of character right like they have
work ethic yeah they have grit um they
love something they're also honest
people who are you know fairly brave i
think about you know things that have
gone well for them and especially about
the things that haven't gone well so you
know i love that we have some heroes
left um some days i wake up and wonder
if we are going to have any left since
um there's a lot to be disappointed
about in the world so anyway i i've
really appreciated um listening to
something like that not only because of
you know athletic accomplishments but
because of character and the role model
that these people are
and what didn't make these clips but
i'll share with you now um i didn't
follow every game he ever played in so i
had to ask him i said eli
did you ever play as quarterback
directly against your brother
and if so how did you do and he said
let's not talk about it i said okay shut
off the cameras now
so i actually don't know how he did but
he was very funny i think we can guess
i don't know i don't know if i can guess
so uh let me see let me give the bard
the last
reflection here i think it's from the
12th night and angela you tell me how
often i think he's right on the money
here when he says
um
this is from the 12th night it says some
people are born great
some people achieve greatness
and some people have greatness thrust
upon them
yes
that kind of covers all the angles there
i think i'm gonna disagree politely with
the bard and say no you no that's not a
lie yeah well you know the bart's not
here to defend himself so
so
i think that people who are great um
are are born with a certain lucky
combination of qualities and
uh they achieve it and circumstances uh
enable them uh to do it so i think all
so it's not or it's not a bunch of ores
all right and
you know the bard will have to come on
and and talk about how i'm wrong we'll
get him on our next exactly it'll be a
great interview
yeah so angela i'm i'm i own a copy of
your book and if we're ever in person
i'm going to get you to sign it um and
it's an important book on the landscape
of how we can all be all that we can be
so thanks for writing that book thanks
for being you and thanks for sharing
your expertise with us here on star talk
sports edition
and i do have a social media platform
that we can find i would like people to
go to characterlab.org and that is a
non-profit website where we give science
away for parents and teachers yay
excellent cool and some percentage of
the people who visit that will also give
you money to do that because it's a not
for profit that would be great too
excellent excellent
gary chuck always good to have you here
pleasure
all right this has been star talk sports
edition
featuring the eli manning interview
nature versus nurture i'm real degrasse
tyson you're a personal astrophysicist
keep looking up
[Music]